monday the 14th of june one
last heave the prime minister is today
expected to announce a four-week delay
to lifting lockdown restrictions in
england
but conservative mps are keeping up the
pressure
what i would very much like to hear are
the objective measures that the
government will be looking at
which will enable them to unlock fully
also this morning nato leaders to
assemble in brussels with russia
and the pandemic fallout topping the
agenda
northern ireland's executive at risk of
being derailed as a dispute breaks out
in the process to replace outgoing first
minister arlene foster
bye bye bibi viniman netanyahu's 12-year
term in power in israel
is finally brought to a close
good morning after a very warm weekend
the heat will continue for some this
week
but gradually fresher conditions coming
from the northwest and could well
trigger
some thunderstorms from the middle of
the week i'll bring you more details
later on
everyone one last heave that's what the
prime minister will ask
the nation to get on board with this
evening as he announces a four-week
delay to the lifting of lockdown
restrictions in england
the decision was rubber stamped by
senior ministers last night
with the 21st of june date now put back
to the 19th of july
boris johnson will argue rising cases of
the so-called delta variant mean more
time is needed
to ensure more people have received both
doses of a covid vaccine
our chief political correspondent john
craig has the details
blooming june in london's queue gardens
but now boris johnson has plotted the
way ahead on his covet roadmap freedom
day in england on june the 21st
is to be delayed for four weeks
obviously i'd
like things just to keep opening up more
and more but
i think it really depends on whether
things are safe or not to do so
it's a tricky one i don't envy the job
of the scientists to
to call it and the politicians to make
the decision the delay is the result of
a third
wave of covert infections which has
persuaded the government to wait
until more people have been vaccinated
and
crucially more people have had a second
jab
there are still two million people over
the age of 50
who haven't been vaccinated and just a
month's breathing space would give us
the opportunity
not only to fully jab more people
including
all the folk who are over 40 but also
give time for the immune response to
kick in
besides the four-week delay until july
the 19th the pm is expected to announce
rules on masks and working from home
guidance remain
table service only in pubs stays and no
change for theaters but the limit of 30
wedding guests
will be relaxed but many tory mps view
the delay in ending england's lockdown
with alarm i can understand why there is
a significant degree of caution
but what i would very much like to hear
are the
objective measures that the government
will be looking at
which will enable them to unlock fully
at some time in the coming weeks
and then the vaccine minister nadim
zahawi's stratford-on-haven constituency
there are fears for the hospitality
trade we've been promised june 21st
um i mean it's looking like maybe it's
going to be pushed back
two weeks or four weeks i mean every
little bit that's
an extra payment an extra rate that
they're going to need to pay and kind of
and those kind of
those things need to be addressed so
much for a sunny outlook for the economy
there could be storm clouds ahead john
craig
sky news
well joining us now is the government
minister health and social care minister
actually edward arge hello to you
lovely to see you thanks for joining us
this morning now um
the delays because of the india variant
as we're being told what caused a spike
in the cases of the india variant
well first of all i'm not going to
preempt what the prime minister might
say
later today um but what we have seen
with this
um with this round is it's highly highly
infectious when i was uh doing the
morning round about a month or so ago
we didn't know whether it was 10 more
infectious or 50
and clearly we now know it's about 40
more infectious than the alpha variant
the um
the so-called kent variant that's what's
driving
the spike and we've gone in a week from
around 12 000 cases of delta variant to
about 42 000. that's a big jump
reflecting the fact that it's that much
more infectious and it's that that's
that's driving the concern
which the prime minister is obviously
looking at very carefully at the moment
we have ourselves to blame though don't
we we should have closed the borders a
couple of weeks earlier when we did with
bangladesh and pakistan well i think
there's a number of points i'd make
there firstly
okay um the variant that we're talking
about the delta variant at the time we
closed the borders that was not a
variant of concern that specific variant
second thing is we've always got to
remember the red list versus the amber
list as it were at red list doesn't
actually mean
the borders are closed if you're a
british citizen even when a country's on
the red list you can still come back
into this country
albeit with the hotel managed quarantine
and we do know there's a very large
number of of british citizens who have
very strong links to india so those
people would still have been able to
return so we've got to be a little bit
careful about understanding the
difference between what happens on the
amber list and the red
yeah they would have been able to return
most certainly because they're british
citizens but they would have been
quarantined in a hotel
and they wouldn't have been returning to
their homes in the northwest of england
and other parts of the country
spreading the virus but i did come back
to that point i made earlier that at the
time
we did put india on the on the red list
what a better way of putting it
that was not a variant of concern that
came a little bit late so we acted
before
that was actually on the on the list and
we will see more variants
i suspect going forward what we've got
to do going forward
which we've done is make sure we have a
robust border regime
but more importantly that we get those
vaccinations in people's arms because
that's the way
we beat variants which will appear one
of those variants i say the alpha
variant um
was from kent within our own country we
will see variants coming from other
countries
and indeed possibly within our own
countries the way to beat them yes is to
be
tough on board restrictions but it's to
get those vaccinations can we at least
accept that if you had closed the border
with
india 14 days before when you did with
bangladesh and pakistan
we may not have been in this position
well i think that's a hypothetical okay
we're saying we may not have been we
don't know it's the short answer well
we've actually known the packaging
i mean the figures were twice as much uh
in india as they were in bangladesh
i discussed this a month or so ago we
were talking about it
um on sky i don't think that would have
uh would have necessarily stopped the
variant coming we will see variants one
of the things we've got to do with this
virus is get those vaccinations in to
get that protection level
up but then we've got to recognize this
disease may well be endemic
for many years we will have to live with
coronavirus covid going forward
vaccinations is the way that we can do
that but you won't accept even the
possibility that if we close the border
of fortnight earlier we might not have
been in this position well it's a
hypothetical okay it's possible
but there's no way of knowing that and i
believe that we
took swift and decisive action we have
some of the toughest
border regimes in the world when it
comes to tackling coronavirus
and i think we acted swiftly and
decisively when that was put on the list
of variants of concern
why didn't we close the border with
india when we did with bangladesh and
pakistan
because we believed the right thing to
do was when that became a variant of
concern we looked at it we followed the
scientific data
we followed the advice we got and we
closed the borders swiftly
on the base of that advice when the
advice was to do so well the scientific
data
on the 25th of march the 7th of april
said that um
india 5.1 of cases that were coming into
the united kingdom
from india were positive cases
our own numbers whereas bangladesh was
only 3.7 and yet we put them on the red
list and we did in india
well as i said equally in the past there
are a number of other factors when we
make those decisions or when the
scientific advice comes on the decisions
one of them is um
genomic sequencing can we understand
these things india has
okay we are world leading this but india
still has an effective genomic
sequencing
program that's another factor that will
have been considered but i go back to
that point
which is that this specific variant the
delta variant
was not um on that variance of concern
list
until as i recall after we made the
decision so we did move swiftly
okay um how do we speed up the vaccine
rollout given that that's what we need
to do
uh i'm guessing that's what the prime
minister is going to say later i'm not
asking you to tell me because i know you
won't
but how do we speed up the vaccine
really i think we are going we are going
as fast as we can with that at the
moment we got
i think an okay weekend figures may vary
sometimes week one second dose is about
275 000
into people's arms yesterday as a by way
of an example
the key for us is to catch up with those
second doses hence
the reduction in the interval from 12 to
eight weeks for the over
50s we've got the supply we know we've
got the supply to be able to do that
and one of the key things i would say is
when you're able when you are eligible
to come forward either for a first dose
or for the second days please do because
we can point out where we want
everyone who's eligible to actually come
forward and get those jabs so we've got
a gap of about
10 million 9 10 million to make up in
terms of difference between first and
second doses
we're really keen to make sure that
everyone gets that second dose
as soon as they are eligible hence the
12 to 8 weeks
partly because it's better for everyone
but partly because
we've seen the latest public health
england evidence there'll be more
research done on this with one dose
you are 33 roughly 33 protected
against the delta variant with two doses
that goes up to 81
and that's the key to being able to
safely ease restrictions and at what
point
will we as a nation be comfortable with
this virus we know that the numbers
um of people contracting kovid 19 the
delta variant
are increasing exponentially but but the
death rate is
remaining about the same at what stage
do we accept that we have to live with
this virus well as
you heard me say there okay i think we
have to once we've got people vaccinated
once we've got those first and second
doses crucially second doses
into people's arms and once we see that
link
clearly severed between getting the
disease and
hospitalizations and severity of disease
and we're seeing some really positive
news on that
although with the delta variant we are
seeing the numbers in hospital creeping
up a bit i think there are just over a
thousand
um at the weekend but when you look back
it was something like 38 000 at the peak
in january so we are seeing
that that severing of the link between
the disease and hospitalizations and
death and i think
that on that basis i think everyone will
will recognize that there comes a point
where we do have to live with this
disease
and recognize that it's you cannot go
for a zero covid
approach you have to live with it and
vaccination is the key to that so i
think once we've got those second doses
in people's arms once we've got that
level of protection up to around 81
percent
then i think people will be more
comfortable with it and we can see
uh we can see more easily and if we
extend lockdown will be extending the
follow scheme
well i know that um and and quite
rightly you haven't tempted
me to speculate on what the prime
minister will say later but i know
that when he addresses his decisions
sets out what he
uh intends to do around the easing on
the 21st he will address those points as
well
that could that they are the table
they're things he is i think he is very
mindful of the need for businesses and
others
to get the support they need if if they
uh continue to be
locked down or unable to open but i
don't want to preempt what he'll say but
i know he's very sensitive to those
days in fact that's potentially still on
the table what about weddings fifty
thousand couples if we if we delay for a
month theoretically
fifty thousand couples will have to take
that big red pen to their list
again they we're chatting to a guy later
he's had to cancel his wedding three
times
postponed his wedding three times so far
um absolute torture is how he describes
it
what concessions might there be for them
well you're absolutely writing the key
word there was you said again there will
be a lot of couples who
planned hope to do it put a line through
it done it again and we showed it again
not only does that cost money but
emotionally that's incredibly difficult
for for couples who want to have their
special day and want to get married
again i'm not going to preempt what the
prime minister will say later but i know
that
weddings and people in that particular
situation
will be very much um in his mind at the
moment and it's one of the things he's
been looking at
he's because he's just got married
himself so he realizes the challenges of
the big day
um so that is something that he's
looking it will be something in the
context of
what his announcement is later that will
be one of the things i know that he will
be giving
very careful consideration to you're
teasing us you're enticing us with what
he might be saying later on it's a good
build up to um hearing from the prime
minister will mps get to vote on the
restrictions
yeah my understanding is yes we've been
very clear that um
where there's a substantive change
whatever that may be
i mean obviously if he's easing them um
then the road map continues as normal if
he does announce the delay
then of course we're clear where there's
a change to that road map were he to do
so
parliament would have to say okay do we
have enough stock
of a vaccine in the united kingdom at
the moment to reduce
the gap between first and second doses
to say eight weeks
we're confident so the advice reducing
for the over fifties for example from
twelve weeks are you pointing to eight
weeks
no no i'm not did you see that
i would not have that i would not have
dreamt of doing that okay but no
twelve to eight weeks and we are
confident that we can do that it's the
right thing to do it's safe
um but that also we've got the supplies
deliver on that commitment so we do so
we are confident that we can deliver on
that and that we will get those
um stick to that key commitment which is
the by the end of july
adults having it all adults have you had
both of yours yet um i've had my first
one
okay which shows i'm a little bit later
i'm i'm not quite over 50 yet okay okay
we're going to move on from age and
if you mention it again you're not
coming back talk to me about northern
ireland
what on earth is going on uh we've heard
uh that the french didn't feel that
northern ireland was part of the united
kingdom that's what the foreign
secretary said the french said don't be
ridiculous
we of course accept that it's part of
the sovereign nation of the united
kingdom and northern ireland
um it's not going to go away this issue
no i mean i
hope that president macron misspoke when
he said that
um and i hope that it's not reflective
of perhaps an attitude in brussels or a
view of
northern ireland quite clearly it is as
you say an integral part of the united
kingdom
northern ireland protocol is in place it
is challenging
at times but we've got to do everything
we can which is exactly what we're doing
to make sure that we honor obligations
um
north-south but also east-west and the
prime minister's been very clear
that making sure that northern ireland
gets the supplies it needs continues to
have
be treated as an equal in the united
kingdom is of paramount importance to
him
i hope that in the discussions which we
saw last week and continue to have with
the european commission we've set out
what we think
is needed to make it work i hope that
they will respond
in kind with a comprehensive and
pragmatic
offer and in those discussions but the
prime
has been very clear that regardless of
that he will do what is necessary
to make sure northern ireland continues
to be treated fairly as an equal part of
the united kingdom
a lot of criticism from former prime
minister gordon brown he's very critical
of the way boris johnson is treating
at northern ireland talking about i mean
it was a dire warning he said
the future of the union is at stake
unless the needs of
all four nations are nurtured um
northern ireland certainly feels like a
poor relation at the moment if what our
reporters out and about
are getting that impression will we
extend
the uh period past the 30th of june if
necessary
in order to try to get a deal over the
life well as i say i'm hopeful that
we'll make progress and that
the european commission will be
pragmatic in its response the prime
minister's
been very clear that all options remain
on the table
to make sure that uh northern ireland
continues to be treated quite rightly
as an integral part of our united
kingdom and he said all options remain
on the table to make sure we do that
that's the 30th of june
well at the moment i'm waiting to see my
perspective from medicine's perspective
i'm waiting to see what the european
commission comes back with we've told
them what we need we've told them
address the issues i hope that they will
come back in the coming days with a
comprehensive
and pragmatic response but the prime
minister's being clear the integrity of
the united kingdom is of paramount
importance
and answer to my question well the
answer to your question is let's wait
and see what brussels comes back with
not awakening isn't there today i'm
afraid yeah we'll hear from the prime
minister later on for now thank you very
much
thank you for joining us mr aga thank
you still to come on the program for you
this morning on the fourth anniversary
of the grenfell tower fire we'll speak
to the shadow housing secretary lucy
powell
that's at half past seven
we're going to discuss new rules making
it easier for gay and bisexual men to
give
blood with ian greene the chief
executive of the terrence higgins trust
that's at 7
35 this morning
dj fat tony is one of thousands of
people in the night time
industry anxiously awaiting confirmation
of that four week delay to lifting the
lockdown
we'll talk with him at 20 past eight
and also in the news for you today just
been talking there haven't we about the
future of northern ireland's devolved
government
hanging in the balance this morning
after sinn fein refused to ratify the
dup's nominee for first minister
the standoff comes as departing first
minister arlene foster prepares to
formally quit
as joint head of the devolved executive
on the fourth anniversary of the
grenfell tower fire labour is warning
unsafe cladding in britain could take
more than 20
years to fix they claim it will take
until 2043
to remove the material if work continues
at the same pace
the government has accused them of
scare-mongering
the former leader of myanmar aung sang
will go on trial today the charges
against her include
accepting bribes and breaking kovid-19
protocols human rights campaigners have
described the child
charges as bogus and politically
motivated
a football club in east sussex is
appealing for information after two
people were caught on cctv
vandalizing its defibrillator kit
buxton fc said the scene was
heartbreaking after they caught the pair
smashing the kit
in the early hours of sunday morning
the biggest issues facing global
security including the rise of china and
the threat from russia
will be discussed at a summit of nato
leaders in brussels
later on today monitoring events for us
our europe correspondent
uh adam parsons is standing by for us
hello to adam a very good morning talk
us through what we're expecting this
morning
yeah i think it's an important uh moment
this one for
nato it's a meeting of all the leaders
including
joe biden boris johnson manuel macron
will be coming here to nato right in the
heart of brussels got
quite a lot on their plate because the
last time that an american president
attended one of these meetings
it was really to discuss whether nato
had a future well joe biden
doesn't hold that sort of doubt but i
think there have been questions about
what exactly is the role of nato
in a world where the cold war has come
to an end so i think these discussions
will revolve around a few things
not least cyber crime for instance uh
if an attack is carried out as was
happened on the colonial pipeline in the
u.s
does that count as a kind of form of war
what about an attack on
on space satellites but also i i think
there's going to be a lot of talk
about russia and about china now russia
we know the positions
of lots of nato members they think that
they are a nation
of menace that that when you put all of
your troops on the ukrainian border
that is clearly an act of intimidation
but there are others here
and president biden foremost among them
who think that
china represents an even greater
existential threat to liberal
democracies
around the world i think he will be
pushing for some kind of statement that
makes clear that nato
recognizes china as a threat to
global stability and i think there are
plenty of murmuring suggesting that nato
this time around
will want to show that it is an
organization that retains some
real teeth i
a reminder that our colleagues at nbc
news have had the chance to sit down
with the russian president vladimir
putin
ahead of his meeting with president
biden you can watch more of that
interview
from this afternoon on nbc ms nbc and
nbcnews.com
as well as here on sky news
one of israel's longest serving prime
ministers
biniman netanyahu has been finally
removed from
office he's been replaced by a former
ally and a coalition of other parties
mark stone reports from jerusalem they
are coalition colleagues no one believed
could ever come together
here a jewish nationalist and an arab in
the same government
in the foreground there was not even a
glance from the man they've ousted
this is israel's new prime minister
naftali bennett
with his final handshake for the
architect of the coalition
yaya lapide
the jizz are a hint of just how hard
fought this was
and how fragile it is
our government will make an effort to
deepen and nurture relations with our
friends in both parties
bipartisan the moment marks the end of
an era for israel
for 12 years benjamin netanyahu has been
ever present the longest serving pm in
israeli history
divisive a master of politics and
defiant to the end
lope
[Applause]
we were never friends i never liked him
i never felt close to him i never felt
that he is a genuine human being
was prime minister before netanyahu they
were both from the same party once
he's he's a genius i mean there
there will be no one that can compete
with him in on television
lawrence olivier you know
he is he is a great performer but when
you look at the substance
of things the divisions
within the israeli society today are
greater than ever before
internationally it is the palestinian
issue which dominates
and here views are set i think
netanyahu's legacy has been one of the
most if not the most destructive legacy
for israel for the whole region
and i think in in many ways by
legitimizing
fascism and violence and manipulation
and control
as well as corruption
that he has created a situation where
the chances of peace have become all
that more difficult if not impossible
the victors are always more vocal than
the losers and in central tel aviv they
celebrated the end of an era
naftali bennett will serve two years as
prime minister
before handing over to centrist yaya
lapid that is of course if this bizarre
cross-spectrum coalition
lasts that long mark stone sky news in
jerusalem
coming up in just a few moments time
we've got some images of a teenager that
you might not recognize when he was
younger but you'll know who he is now
what am i talking about you'll find out
after the weather with kirsty hi kirsty
good morning
good morning good morning kay
looking like a glorious day for some of
us today but changes coming
this week could be some thundry
downpours
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
weekend for some of us we are going to
see more in the way of sunshine as we
head
through the rest of the week but
increasingly fresher air coming in from
the northwest
and could well trigger some heavy
thundery downpours through the middle
part of the week
so for most of us today we've got some
sunny weather but there is this zone of
thicker cloud across northern england
and wales this morning
bringing with it some damp and drizzly
weather that will push southwards
and weaken as it goes it's quite murky
and misty around the coast of the
southwest but
very hot in the sunshine yet again in
the south fresher further north for
scotland northern ireland republic it's
a blustery day
with sunny spells and a scattering of
showers in the far north and west so
fresher in the north
still very hot in the south
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now as promised a little bit of pop
history is going
up for auction later on today
do you recognize that
young man my day
[Music]
it's this recording of 15 year old
ed sheeran appearing in a school
performance of greece he plays the
character rump in the two-hour long
performance
the same auctioneers last year so one of
uh the first ed sheeran cds for
50 000 pounds
still to come on the program before
you'll be speaking to the shadow housing
secretary lucy powell in just a moment
stay tuned
pony about half a mile from the turkish
coast and
it's evident that is the boat seriously
overcrowded
this is one of the most severe viruses
in the world
i'm alex crawford and i'm sky's special
correspondent based in
istanbul
that's it it got us then
there's a lot of action going on
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in the news
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail
her arms look at her arms i can put my
entire
hand round
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
once it takes hold it's very very
difficult for these firefighters to
get a grip of it to get on top of it and
put it out
the world's largest falls now
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
getting up close and personal with a
rhino
this is what makes the job so fantastic
[Music]
hello my name is nadja frontier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
far i've been here for five months and
it is an absolutely wonderful experience
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental problems related to waste
pollution the frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
in exchange if you recycle to get a
treat
[Music]
hello again everybody welcome to the
breakfast program
21st of june was going to be freedom day
wasn't it but we're expecting to hear
from the prime minister
later on this evening about what might
happen on the 21st of june within the
last few minutes the health minister
edward argher has hinted that the prime
minister
could consider extending the furlough
scheme
as well later on today
well i know that um and and quite
rightly you haven't tempted me to
speculate on what the prime minister
will say later but i know that when he
addresses his decisions sets out what he
uh intends to do around the easing on
the 21st he will address those points as
well
that could that they are the table
they're things he is i think he is very
mindful
of the need for businesses and others to
get the support they need if
if they uh continue to be locked down or
unable to open but i don't want to
preempt what he'll say but i know he's
very sensitive to those
those in fact ron paul is here good
morning good morning what did you make
of what he had to say yeah i thought
even though we didn't get that
confirmation but i think we were never
going to get the confirmation of the
four weeks from edgar this morning
he was sort of sketching out the context
and the backdrop to this i think
um yes maybe some extra financial
support we know furlough
is being scaled back from july even
though it's extended through to
september and some people want to see
that stay at
sort of full throttle 100 um or 80
wage furlough from july as well on
weddings hinting that there could be
something around that as well
but also i think setting what is likely
to be the explanation for this delay
when it eventually comes that this isn't
about trying to
stay in restrictions forever to get to
zero covid he said zero covered won't
work we have to learn to live with this
but saying this is about getting nine or
ten million extra
second doses into arms so we can bring
that protection up for the people that
really need it
so i think that is probably going to be
what we are going to hear when this
delay comes out
to tell people not to worry this isn't
an endless slippery slope of
restrictions that will go on forever
this is about getting extra jabs into
arms over the next four weeks
but still no acceptance that the delay
in closing the border with india had
anything to do with the rampage of this
delta vaccine at delta variant forgive
me yeah i think the closest he came
to it was saying well it might have but
we can't know i mean i think it seems
pretty obvious that
uh this variant was first detected in
india if we had acted sooner on india
then
we would have had few cases being
imported um into the country
the government have been pretty unclear
on their on their explanation on this
matt hancock has repeatedly
um said that uh places like pakistan and
bangladesh were in worse positions and
he has data to back that up whereas our
own data
or not even ours our data that we've
looked at that we've taken from test and
trace
shows precisely the opposite so i think
again
this is going to be one of many big
questions that follows the government
around especially
if in four or five weeks time we are
having exactly the same arguments about
whether we should ease up or not okay
thanks very much rob thank you let's put
that to the shadow housing secretary
lucy powell should we hello team as paul
it's good to talk to you this morning
thanks for joining us on the programme
do you think if we had closed the
borders earlier with india that we would
still be in this position this morning
well undoubtedly nice to see you okay by
the way and i see you back again
um i mean undoubtedly we were too late
to put india on the red list and that
certainly i think had everything to do
with the fact that the prime minister
was supposed to be going out there
himself
so there was a real political reluctance
within government
to do that so i think that three four
week delay on on india being on the red
list
has undoubtedly ceded the delta variant
much more widely here in the uk than it
than it might otherwise have done
you used to um service shadow business
minister i think i'm right in saying
that uh lucy powell
um do you think i'm not saying that the
um health minister said that they were
definitely going to extend the furlough
scheme but he sort of hinted at it
during my interview just a short time
ago i'm guessing of course
labour would support that well we
absolutely would if
there is going to be a delay which it
now seems uh almost certain that there
is going to be
businesses need to know that especially
those businesses and they're the same
businesses that have been at the sharp
end of this for the last 15 months the
night clubs the wedding sector the large
event
those that have been completely closed
uh through most of this time
need to know that they've got that extra
support
there to remain closed and many other
businesses will continue to be
affected by social distancing and other
measures which stopped them
from getting their usual trade and and
profitability
in their businesses so we've always said
that business support
has to sit alongside the public health
restrictions so for as long as they
remain the business support packages
need to remain as well
and i think we also need to see today
more from the government about what
they're going to do
on public health terms if the delay
happens
how are we going to get more people to
get those second doses
will they bring forward as we've been
calling for for weeks
uh more targeted vaccine surges in the
communities and places that have been
most affected
like here in greater manchester and
lancashire and other parts of the
country
they're still not uh doing that so we do
need a ramping up of these things in
order to be confident
that the next stage of the roadmap can
be reached in in that four week time if
that
is when it's going to be at what point
will labour be comfortable with where
the virus is
in the united kingdom uh we heard from
the minister
and acceptance that we will always have
to live with kovid
19 but what would labour be comfortable
with
well i think he's he's absolutely right
we are now reaching
coming towards that point where we do
have to
switch from living in fear of the virus
to living
alongside the virus knowing that through
the vaccine programme we have protected
the vast majority of the most vulnerable
and we've protected
society at large but there will still be
incidents of infections in this country
and i think getting
to from this point where i think the
psychology of the country is very
fearful
to that point we'll take really clear
and effective leadership and i'm not
quite sure
we're getting that so i want to see
stronger leadership to take the whole
country
uh through uh on on that journey and
we do need to have a different kind of
conversation to get us there and there
will need to be changes so for example
here in greater manchester where we have
got large numbers of
of infections that in itself is having
quite a devastating impact because
lots of people are being pinged by the
app so they've got to stay at home for
10 days
that's having a big impact on businesses
who can't operate because their staff
are all being sent home
we are yet again here in greater
manchester seeing great disruption
to children's education because schools
are having to send home
large numbers of peoples to self-isolate
so getting to that point of living with
the virus and living alongside these
infections
will have to change the way in which we
deal with infections
as well but what i would say from up
here is the vaccines
are working the over 65s are that the
infection rates among those are largely
flat
hospital rates are nothing like they
were last time and it's largely younger
people coming into hospital
and staying for a shorter amount of time
so
the vaccine program is working but we've
got a lot to do
to get us to the place as ed argher was
saying this morning
of living with this virus and i need to
see much stronger leadership and more
effective communication i think to take
the country there
your former prime minister gordon brown
uh
was suggesting in the newspapers that
the prime minister needs to tread very
carefully indeed now when it comes to
northern ireland
uh if the union is not uh to start to
to break up he really feels uh that it
is such a serious
threat what do you think the government
needs to do
about the brexit negotiations which are
due to end the deadline is the end
of june before in order to try to
open up this trade corridor again with
northern ireland
well i think gordon brown is absolutely
right to say that we are
at a very difficult perhaps sort of
dangerous
juncture here when it comes to northern
ireland trust
uh in the uk government trusting the
system
um from from many communities across
northern ireland is is is
disappearing fast so we've we've really
got to give this
serious urgency and be prepared to be
flexible
and show compromise i would say that of
the eu
as well i think there is a path there to
tread and
the first things to say is that we've
got the northern ireland protocol
because of the type of brexit that boris
johnson the conservative party wanted
to have and that's why we've ended up in
in the situation that we have
but we we are calling for the government
to
um to be more open to alignment
with the eu on food standards and
veterinary
issues that's what joe biden is is
pressing the government to do
as well because that would unlock 80
percent of the issues
that we're seeing across the sort of
irish sea and in that
so-called sort of border that's
appearing there um so i think there is a
way forward the conservatives
never wanted to do alignment because
they always thought that would put at
risk
a deal with the us a trade deal with the
u.s joe biden has now come along and
said
about the opposite if you want a trade
deal with the us
you need to align with the eu in order
to
deal with these issues of the northern
ireland protocol
okay just want to ask you quickly if i
may given that it's
four years to the day that we all woke
up with those
devastating images of the flames roaring
up the side
of grenfell tower and that so many lives
lost
as a result of that dreadful fire four
years on
people are still going to bed at night
with cladding that sort of cladding on
the side of their buildings what needs
to be done
i mean absolutely and obviously today it
is the anniversary
and today is mainly about remembrance
for the 72 that died
the survivors and all the families and
and those affected
and the survivors and the families from
grenfell
have always been very clear that
what they want to see is faster action
to make sure that nobody else
could possibly go through what they've
gone through and unfortunately four
years on
we are still seeing many buildings
around the country
with the dangerous ac m cladding with
other cladding issues with now
what what people are discovering other
fire remediation issues
and at the pace that we're going and the
pace the government are going out to
make buildings safe it's going to be
another 22 years
before all the high-rise buildings in
this country are made safe so
they set aside five billion pounds worth
of funding
to start putting this right but what we
really need is
very effective leadership strong
leadership bringing all parties together
to actually
get this work done and make buildings
safe because people are living in
unsafe and unsellable high-rise blocks
at the moment and that is not
that is not what we should be wanting uh
four years on from grenfell
okay lucy powell good to talk to you
thanks for taking the time to join us
live from manchester thank you
thank you you believe it's four years
since we saw those images from grenfell
tower the building uh
still there um green hearts atop
that building the inquiry continuing
from today the rules around
gay and bisexual men giving blood are
being eased but there's concern that
some restrictions preventing donations
are remaining
in england to talk about this in more
detail ian green is the chief exec
of the terence higgins trust and he is
with us now hello to you thanks for
joining us this morning ian
let's start with the good news should we
new eligibility rules
mean um gay and bisexual men uh who want
to donate blood now can
yes so i mean this is really a welcome
news meaning that
many more gay and bisexual men uh will
be eligible to
donate blood and blood products based
upon an individualized risk assessment
process up until now a blanket policy
has existed meaning that a man who has
sex with another man
could not donate blood uh three months
until three months have passed from
having
sex so uh a monogamous couple
uh who are only having sex with each
other could not donate blood that's
changing now which is good news
but we don't think this goes far enough
and that was because of concerns about
hiv aids was it
there was a whole range of concerns
about about infections
and hepatitis or hiv but the safety of
blood
products uh means that uh that now the
screening takes place
on all donations and alongside this uh
evidence-based risk assessment process
um
uh and the screening of all blood
products it means that um the blood
supply
can be absolutely guaranteed as being
safe
so this is good news but you don't feel
that these relaxation of the rules go
far enough do you
no because the government in england not
in wales or scotland
have retained some
restrictions on people who have traveled
to africa and other parts of the world
and and also anyone who had sex with
anybody and from certain parts of the
world
and our view is that there's the view of
the expert advisory body
and the sapto and the fair process
which we are a part of um with uh expert
virologists and their view is that uh
the
approach should be exactly the same as
again bisexual men
an individualized risk assessment
process and so
along with colleagues from the national
age trust and the one point voice
network
we've written to matt hancock asking him
to think again
i'm very pleased though that the health
ministers in wales and scotland
are taking advice of the experts and
there are particular challenges for gay
and
uh by black african men why is it so
important for black and black african
communities
in particular for these donations to go
ahead
yeah i mean the the uh it's really
important that more people
are encouraged and to give blood and
blood products
that so many lives are saved every year
and through people who donate blood
but that there's a particular need for
people of color
to give blood and because of the type of
blood
that often people of color will be
behave
and so it's really important that we do
encourage people of color to give blood
and any barriers are put in the way that
restrict that
could actually have a detrimental impact
upon
blood supply that will be given safely
to people who need it
okay good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time to explain that to us
this morning thank you
thanks thank you still to come on the
program for you this monday morning
we're live in london's west end as
theater land waits for the prime
minister's announcement
on delaying the lifting of covid
restrictions
a theater that has been of what you can
see what's happened they
literally overhauled it will take you
there
pisces 3 was a small mini submarine
that was on a job in the north sea sorry
the
atlantic about 150 miles off the coast
of ireland
and what happened was that it had been
its job was effectively to
to relay um cables that were connecting
the telephone cables from canada to the
uk
and what happened was that and there was
a problem with one of the
one of the um the pipes at the back and
water came
in and it sank down to a depth of
sixteen hundred feet
with the two men on board the way i
always try and describe it to people is
if you imagine being in a telephone box
and the telephone box is sitting next to
the empire state building
and this the atlantic sweeps into a
height 10 stories above
and the very top of the empire state
building and that's the predicament that
these men were in
it's an incredible story and it's a
testament to to what's known as the
brotherhood of the sea
and there was a massive rescue operation
that involved
a team from canada who were flown over
by hercules
and aircraft with with their own
miniature submarine and that's the team
they're
they're the americans who were flown
over from san diego
they all relayed at cork when the vicar
voyager ship that was above the
submarine
had to sail back to court to pick them
up and then they got back
onto the actual rescue site and the
terrible thing was that they didn't
actually know exactly where the
submarine was
uh the cable that had been that there
was a boy effectively attached to the
submarine when it was in operations
but that had been disconnected just
before the sinking so they effectively
knew where the haystack was they just
didn't know where the cable was that
roger
chapman who was one of the survivors
wrote a memoir about it just a couple of
years after the
after the events that came out in 75-76
but what i wanted to do and the most
crucially before
the the rescuers had to die effectively
was tell the incredible story because
that his book told the story
from inside the submarine effectively
whereas what i wanted to do in my book
was was unite all these incredible
people from um
from barrow and firmness and scot sorry
and power and furnace
in england and from vancouver in canada
and also from san diego who bonded
together
in this incredible adventure to try and
get them up so it was one of these
stories where it
is about that that noble thing of of
people putting their lives on the line
and to rescue two individuals
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sun
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
hello there we've got a weakening
weather front moving southwards across
parts of england and wales today
they'll bring in a little bit more cloud
and introduce fresher air from the north
breezy with sunshine and showers across
scotland and
northern ireland temperatures though in
the south still very warm in the
sunshine across southern england
up to 28 celsius so strong
summer sunshine and grass pollen levels
peaking as well
very high for many southern eastern
areas low to moderate grass pollen
elsewhere
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
and if you're suffering with hay fever
this morning i hear you
now whatever happens today with the
prime minister's announcement on
lockdown
theaters will be among the last
businesses to reopen at full
capacity uh joining us now is the howard
panther owner of the trafalgar theater
hello to
howard
good morning to you good morning good
morning tell me about the renovations
that you've had done at the theater
well we've done a fantastic job in
taking it right the way
back on the one hand to how it was in
the 1930s so some
some of the decoration uh that you may
have just seen
and some of the wonderful artwork that
we've discovered
hasn't been seen for about 90 years but
as we peel back
the layers of of plasterboard and other
coverings
we discovered what i call tutankhamun's
tomb for the first time it's absolutely
glorious
it's been a work that we've done with
many historic societies with many
pictures with many drawings
and with lots of crafts people creating
something that's absolutely exquisite
and what i think is great about it
is when you're in the building you
actually think this is a good place to
be i like being here
this is special and that's obviously one
of the things that theatre's got to
offer
that it's special places with special
things happening in them
oh i love art deco it's absolutely my
era is there a particular
piece that you are most fond of
um well they're all different of course
i think this one is about as particular
and special as i can think of
it's a bit like a savoy hotel in feel
but it's actually more detailed
every inch of it is covered with the
original or
reproduction of the original uh
design and it just shows the imagination
of the artists at the time the other
thing of course we've done is we've made
it
fit for modern customers so that the
seats are bigger
and much more comfortable and most
important of all i always joke about
this but it's absolutely true
we've got masses more ladies toilets and
i always think in theater
that's one of the things that some
theaters lack but this one has got
masses of toilets
and so the ladies will all be quite
properly uh comfortable in the theater
yeah because we always have to rush
either you go to the bar or you go to
the loo generally when you go to the
theater so i'm pleased to hear
that that's the case if the 21st of june
doesn't go ahead um what would that few
extra weeks of extension mean for you
well i think the problem is that as
boris throughout this whole roadmap
period as you know has said
almost consistent consistently there is
nothing in the data
that makes him think the 21st of june
has not
is not going to be met so naturally
we've had to mobilize
hundreds and indeed thousands of people
working across the industry
to get ready to start at the 21st of
june so
a lot of people's jobs will be in peril
a lot of uh
investment will be in peril because
we've been keeping
this entity in this industry going we
and others been keeping this industry
industry going for 15 months
out of our own investors and our pockets
it's not kept going by the government
it's been kept going
by us and now we've ready to go we've
marched the army up the hill
and now if we've got to march it down
again you can imagine the damage that
will cause
to mental health to social well-being
being
and to the economic strength of london
and of other cities where we have
theaters
you look down the the strand which is
just around the corner from here
half the shops offices restaurants
clubs pubs are closed they're boarded up
they a lot of those places won't open up
again and that's the peril that's facing
theater at the moment
if we can't open up again all those
thousands of jobs
that huge impact on the economy you know
london
is the biggest driver in the uk economy
and you know that the cultural
industries
are either the third or the fourth
biggest contributor to gdp
so to take that away for another month
means losing millions of pounds
and millions and thousands of jobs i say
not millions of jobs
thousands of jobs so it's very serious
indeed particularly
when of course it's serious covert and
of course i know personally it's serious
from various things that happen in my
family
and i'm not diminishing any of those
facts but the fact of the matter is
hospitalizations are basically flat the
vaccines work
they work and
and mortalities thank god a tiny so it's
just completely disproportionate
that's what we all feel so howard let's
look to the positives by the end of july
you will have jersey boys on
in that theater now i have seen jersey
boys
i kid you not 18 times at the theater
um talk to me about what your favorite
frankie valley song is do you have one
uh oh what a night it's gotta be hasn't
it i mean over the night is just one of
the greatest
greatest hymns to enjoyment to the
special nature
of relationships and it's just a
fabulous tune
and it's been a hit all over the world
not by accident
because people love oh what a night
we're out of time sahara it's
great to see you can't take my eyes off
you is my favorite obviously really
given that i've watched it 18 times good
to talk to you thank you